foreign
which was newly examined by Islamabad
High Court
and Islam about high court has declared
his arrest under proper legal procedures
and under lawful Authority
so this is an arrest which is not
motivated by any
political victimization
this is an arrest which was not done at
the behest of the government
it is an arrest that was made by the
national
accountability Bureau
the institution that is supposed to
look after
corruption cases in the country
and it is an independent body
unfortunately
the response that was given by followers
of Mr Imran Khan
have I think created a great
embarrassment for their own party
and for him
the scenes that came on the media of
loot
and blunder
are most deplorable
because Mr Khan had been championing
all through his career
that he stands for rule of law
he had been lecturing the people of
Pakistan what is and plunder
are most deplorable
because Mr Khan had been championing
all through his career
that he stands for rule of law
he had been lecturing the people of
Pakistan what is rule of law in Western
democracy
and today
he and his followers are showing
examples of worst fascist
responses that one can
ever find in history
this is the worst kind of demagoguery
the worst kind of
fascism
that is being demonstrated by a leader
whose rise to fame was Sports
as a sportsman
he ought to be championing Sportsman
spirit
tolerance
and respecting rule of law
but instead he has chosen a path of
spreading Anarchy
chaos
and destruction in the country
only to protect himself from
accountability
Mr Imran Khan on number of occasions
said that if ever there was a case
against him he will voluntarily present
himself before the authorities for
investigation
and as you know
that this case and in which he has been
arrested by NAB
is a case of graft
a case of embezzlement
a case of Corruption of 160 million
pounds
which is 60 billion Pakistani rupees
160 million pound which was confiscated
by UK crime agency
on charges of money laundering
from a Pakistani real estate Tycoon
Mr Imran Khan under a fraudulent
deal
under a
deal of self
benefit
he
instead of depositing That 160 million
pounds in National ex checker
he allowed that amount to be deposited
in the state bank account to settle the
dues of the same person
who was fined 160 million rupees so in
fact
160 million pounds which were
confiscated from this person for money
laundering in UK Imran Khan returned
that confiscated money back to him so
that he could settle his account with
Supreme Court
now this is worst kind of corruption
and he did this
to gain personal benefits
everyone knows that he created a trust
with his and his spouse's name as owners
and got benefit of huge chunk of land
and there were also audio recordings
which talked of some jewelry Gifts of
jewelry that Mr Imran Khan and his wife
got from the same person
now this is not a small case it is 60
billion rupees of Pakistani taxpayers
money which would have been deposited in
the national account
Mr Imran Khan Through a mellified action
allowed that money
to be paid back to the same person who
was found guilty of money laundering for
his own personal benefit
so now my question is if such a case
happens
in Western Country or any country
whether it is UK or USA what would the
law do
if there is a case where any prime
minister or head of con the government
is found to be indulging in such
practice won't anti-corruption agency or
crime agency in that country investigate
that case won't they proceed to arrest
that person if he is not cooperating
with the investigation agencies
you saw that before whenever he was
summoned to the court he would appear in
Courts at his own leisure
as and when he deemed fit he will appear
before court and that too only when
Court would give him a final warning but
before that he even defied the orders of
the courts and not only did not appear
before courts but he even went to the
extent of threatening a lady judge
when security agencies went to his home
to serve that summon of appearance
before court there was attack on the
security agencies Patrol bombs were
thrown
dozens of policemen were injured
seriously injured
Stones were thrown there were Firearms
there were terrorists present known
terrorists there
so and everyone saw those images how
PTI supporters protected his house and
they were attacking the law enforcement
agencies who had gone to just serve
notice from the court similarly what
happened in judicial complex in
Islamabad is before each one of you
not only that he attacked the judicial
complex we have a history
Imran Khan had earlier attacked Pakistan
television building the place where we
are sitting
in 2014 this place was ransacked not
only he ransacked Pakistan television
compound or offices he also ransacked
Parliament he attacked the parliament
now will United States forgive those who
attacked capital
or at the behest of President Trump no
they are all facing charges
and I think it was a big mistake at that
time
by the government
do not arrest him for
attacking the parliament because
Parliament is very sacrosanct but in
order to not create more hostility we
showed lot of magnanimity but Imran Khan
misunderstood or took advantage of that
gracious approach of the government to
create to maintain political Harmony in
the country and he has gone further and
he has not only attacked
yesterday his followers have attacked
State Properties
security
institutions properties but he has even
gone to the extent of attacking public
transport
and worst of all burdening schools
now who have been who has been burning
schools in Pakistan it has been the
extremists and now the credit goes to
PTI
who have burned schools also in this
country now how can any society tolerate
this kind of behavior this kind of
lawlessness this kind of Anarchy so the
law has to take its course and those who
have indulged in these kinds of
activities will be taken to task but why
want to assure you that there is no
political band data
there is no political victimization
in any of the actions that have been
taken by NAB it is an independent
Authority
NAB has arrested Mr Imran Khan under a
lawful legal warrant which has been
cleared by the high court and declared
to be legal
now Imran Khan who was arresting all the
opposition leaders during his term as
prime minister I went through a
punishment in a death sentence for more
than two months
and was later on cleared by the high
court that it was a baseless case
but we never resorted to such tactics
Mr Nawaz Sharif was arrested Mr shabash
Sharif was arrested all of our front
line leaders were arrested but did pmln
ever resort to such kind of violence no
has people's party or other parties
resorted to such kind of violence loan I
mean no other party has ever shown this
kind of behavior that PTI supporters and
Mr Imran Khan has shown which clearly
shows that he is on a path of creating
chaos in the society
he was ousted not through any conspiracy
but for the first time in the history of
the country a prime minister was removed
through a constitutional process of no
confidence
his own allies left him
there was no PTI dissident who voted in
no confidence motion
it was just his own allies
who left him after his failures after
his poor conduct and they felt very
unhappy with the government and they
left him as simple as that and majority
came on the opposition side it was a
constitutional vote of no confidence in
it he was ousted instead of accepting
that decision in a sportsman manner
he said it's either my way or Highway
either country will accept me as prime
minister or I will not allow this
country to be run he went to the extent
of trying to sabotage the IMF agreement
he went to the extent of sabotaging
country's relief efforts after the
climate disaster that hit us his party
went to the extent of
calling International agencies not to
help the government in the wake of that
climate disaster
so unfortunately the behavior that PTI
has been demonstrating has been very
unethical undemocratic and purely
fascist
and we are reminded how in history
demagogues have caused destruction to
their societies but Pakistan will not be
allowed to become Hostage to such
politics of demagoguery or fascism we
are a democratic country if Imran Khan
feels that he has been unfairly arrested
he can prove his innocence before the
court of law just as we did
I proved my innocence before court of
law all the leaders from opposition they
contested their cases before courts that
is the Democratic way but this is no way
that you start inciting people for
violence you cause destruction in the
country you cause loss to the economy
and you try to bring bad image to the
country internationally
so I just wanted to clarify this that Mr
Imran Khan does not face any political
when data he does not face any political
victimization he faces the
accountability for his own misdeeds of
corruption in which he indulged and we
are witness because in cabinet cabinet
secretary testified that this agreement
which there is presented to UK
authorities to transfer the money
instead of government of Pakistan
account to Supreme Court account to
settle private persons fine
this agreement was never shown to the
cabinet meeting cabinet secretary said
the meeting had concluded and Mr Imran
Khan just shared an alcohol Shield
envelope that this is an important
agreement and cabinet should approve it
and when some of the cabinet ministers
questioned that at least we should be
shown they were snapped
so this is how in a very opaque manner
in a very non-transparent manner he
carried out this fraud embezzlement
graft and now he's not willing to be
accountable held accountable
something which he has been demanding
for everyone in this country but it
seems that Mr Khan believes in
accountability of 220 million pakistanis
but not for himself not for his party
this is not democracy this is not rule
of law this is fascism thank you
yesterday
is not going to take any action against
instrumental
first of all the security agencies will
present their report and whatever they
recommend government will act
accordingly but let me say that we
cannot have double standards in this
country
that for some people you hold them
accountable even if they burn a police
post
and for others even they do much more
daring acts and the state shuts its eyes
this will create implications this will
have implications for Pakistan so there
will be one law anyone who takes law
into their hand anyone who acts in a
manner which is anti-state the actions
that
PTI followers were committing yesterday
were not against the government
they were against the people of Pakistan
and they were against the state of
Pakistan because they targeted important
state institutions they import they
targeted important state infrastructure
they targeted schools this is not
acceptable at all we have fought a great
war against terrorists who used to burn
our schools who used to stop our girls
from going to schools and today PTI is
doing the same thing it is burning
schools to deny education to our
children we cannot allow this kind of
behavior and all those who are involved
in the case will be investigated by the
NAB you can ask this question to NAB
because they are dealing with this case
but I am sure that they will carry out
Justice and anyone who is related to
this crime will be investigated
foreign
this was done very spontaneously and
because these normally in 75 years
people have not crossed the red lines
some of these Institute for example uh
during Zia martial law people's party
went through a lot of persecution but
you don't find that people's party
workers crossed that red line anywhere
during Musharraf martial law pmln went
through worst persecution but no one
ever crossed that red line because end
of the day these are our state
institutions if we weaken them we also
strengthen non-state actors who are
trying to destabilize Pakistan so
Pakistan needs to preserve its security
institutions respect them so therefore
it was not really expected that anything
like this would happen and I think PTI
yesterday crossed many deadlines
foreign
s have taken place in provinces so
provincial government and provincial Law
and Order agencies are
taking stock of the situation and also
apprehending the culprits they are
trying to recognize them through video
images and trying to gather their record
but let me assure you that we cannot
allow such precedence to be repeated
uh Ministry of interior will I think
give a statement about that
I don't have exact figures because it is
in the domain of provincial governments
so we can get numbers from them and
share with you
yeah government is taking all the
Necessities security precautions and as
you know that these violence incidents
were not outpour of any public
demonstration these were targeted
demonstrations planned by Mr Imran Khan
himself
by his own party workers so these uh
demonstrations or violent actions by no
means show that there was any public
support for uh their cause or their call
these were Rank and file of PTI workers
who had been given these tasks most of
their Punjab assembly ticket holders
were told to bring people so this is
this was an organized attack on
government buildings on state
infrastructure by PTI and well rehearsed
and well planned under the supervision
of Mr Imran Khan who was fearing that
they may be his arrest may be coming in
days in coming days so to you know
protect himself from such arrests he had
carried out detailed meetings and plans
for his own workers to put up such kind
of actions to create fear amongst
government
departments not to touch him no person
in Pakistan is untouchable
each every person in Pakistan is
accountable before law so Imran Khan may
be may be a big Superstar or maybe a big
celebrity if he says that he is above
Constitution he is above law he's above
accountability he's mistaken and my
request to his followers is that if you
truly believe in the cause of rule of
law if you truly believe in the cause of
accountability then set an example and
have the confidence if you believe that
this case is based on Melody if this
case is not true then he will be set
free by the courts but if he is guilty
then you cannot protect his corruption
by such violent Acts you are also
becoming guilty of protecting his
corruption and causing damage to the
State Properties
thank you very much
conference
yeah because it is an ongoing situation
but I can safely say that the door the
damage caused to State infrastructure
and properties runs into billions
you know they have really destroyed many
police vans buses Metro Bus Station many
schools so this is a loss to the
taxpayer this is a loss to the poor
people of Pakistan they will have to now
rebuild this infrastructure but we will
hold those who have carried out this
violence also accountable so that they
also pay for the damages they have done
is there any
news yeah the government has taken the
necessary security measures and
preventive measures so that we do not
allow them to you know carry out more
actions as they have done yesterday
and inshallah we are hopeful that
security will be back to normal there
are handful peoples few people from the
party who are doing this Common People
common man is not part of this unrest so
government is taking all the necessary
precautions and measures to protect
important buildings to to protect
foreigners so I think there is no grave
threat to security or serious threat
anyone
yeah hi my name is
police lines turned into a sub jail and
do you
do your following October
and more importantly what does the
government stance on PTI leadership
being arrested
uh why were they arrested yeah first of
all you know this quote was shifted on
the recommendation of the local
administration because they created such
a scene and judicial complex last time
that there was a security situation in
the judicial complex so in order to keep
Law and Order uh and security of the
concerned people and the judges it was
important to take necessary precautions
so as a precautionary measure it was
shifted to these police lines safe
premises because last time they created
a very Rowdy scene there and violent
scene at the judicial complex so we did
not want to see a replay of any such
action again
the PTI leadership who are part of the
provocation incitement and violence
which it was seen yesterday across the
country obviously they will be held
accountable and if there are cases
against them for inciting violence
police will arrest them
and Mr Imran Khan will face the law if
he is considered innocent he will
contest the elections but if he's found
guilty of corruption then obviously he
will have to face the consequences of
that corruption
thank you okay
Pakistan South Carolina
news conferences
[Music]